[Music]
when a daughter vanished a father would
not stop searching for the truth gary
Bardwell was so close with his 27 year
old daughter Jessie that he feared
something terrible had happened to her
when he couldn't reach her and he
believed her new boyfriend had something
to do with it
tomorrow night 48 hours correspondent
Maureen Maher looks at how Jessie's
father would not give up his quest
here's a preview I remember having a
nightmare that something was terribly
wrong Jessie was was killed and when I
woke up it was just a dream
but in his heart of hearts Gary Bardwell
knew it was more than a dream it was an
omen and I felt it in May 2016
Jessie vanished from her home in
Richardson Texas where she'd been living
with her boyfriend of four months Jason
Lowe detective Kieran Hale was assigned
to the case that's the father of three
girls I was very determined to get to
the bottom of what had happened to Jesse
Bart would Jason lo told him Jesse had
left their apartment in the morning of
May 8th and never returned
Jason still seemed unconcerned four days
later the detective recorded their
conversation the day detectives searched
the apartment there was a line of
cocaine on the table but it wasn't the
drugs they were interested in it was an
odor coming from the garage it's a smell
that do you never forget it was the
smell of death and it was coming from
the back of Jason Lowe's black Audi
there was no Jesse Bardwell but even
without a body
Jason was charged with murder I had no
doubt that he had killed her but he did
doubt they would ever find her Texas is
a huge state there are a hundred million
different places you could hide a body
in Texas the police eventually found
Jesse Birdwell what they found no father
should ever see and she was thrown away
like a piece of
a lot of times you can't recognize evil
you just just one of those things that
you know when you see it
Jason's court-appointed attorney
Andy Farkas says he is sure that Jason
did not murder Jessie he's not so sure
he can convince a jury so he wrote tests
his case I've been a lawyer for 42 years
in a mock trial I have never done this
with surprising results not guilty the
defense now believes Jason Lowe could
walk out of jail a free man but Garry
Birdwell will not let that happen
give me ten minutes in a room and I
would kill him Maury Maher joins us at
the table must have been torturous for
that dad because he didn't like him from
the very beginning the boyfriend no I I
think every one of us has a friend or
family member who starts a relationship
with somebody else and everyone thinks
why are they with that person except
Delia this happened so fast over the
course of four months she just stopped
talking to her friends the only access
anyone had to her was by way of him and
the father kept saying when do I step in
when do I step out she's an adult how
did they convince the jury that he's not
guilty
so the mock jury has the defense
attorney telling him the story so you
have a person who's measured giving the
correct tone the exact words that he
wants to use that's entirely different
than somebody who's a pathological liar
who gets up on the stand is very
emotional and doesn't always follow the
same line of story that the defense
attorney wants them to so what was the
most challenging thing for prosecutors I
think that the body was so badly
decomposed while it was ruled a homicide
they didn't know how it happened and
sometimes a jury needs to have
everything spelled out for them they
don't connect the dots the way the
prosecution would like they couldn't
explain how the murder took place they
could not say how she was killed Thank
You Maureen you can watch Maureen Mara's
full report it's called taken away
tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central it's all
part of a 48 hours double feature which
kicks off at 9:00 8:00 central tomorrow
night right here on CBS